finally Pauli settling down that's weird  yes things are getting is serious for  Polly D and Aubrey O'Day we met while  filming the soon premier show famously  single yeah buddy  so Annie T caught up with Polly's in  Jersey Shore co-star Nicole Snooki  Polizzi to talk her new show Nicole and  Jionni's Shore flip at least one of us  knows what we're doing  I got we had to get her take on the  romance I've met Aubrey a while ago like  in Jersey Shore days and she was always  very sweet  um so Aubrey dating Paulie I think it's  amazing they were gorgeous together um  so I'm happy for them but finally  paulie's settling down that's weird  as for Snooki's romantic life well me  and Jionni don't really have sex because  we have two kids so to be honest with  you when he did put the hard hat on he  had a hammer on I was like my husband's  really sexy but um no it didn't spice up  anything because if anything we were  more tired because we're flipping a  house so I just had those fantasies